picture a medical emergency
a call to a first responder the first
moments of the call could mean the
difference between life
and death what's the diagnosis is the
patient in a critical condition
what if artificial intelligence could
support the responder
helping them make the right decisions
that's exactly what's happening here
in denmark computer learning means the
system instantly sees the bigger picture
drawing on the experience from millions
of calls from a global network
allowing it to reach a quick decision
computers never forget they never need
coffee they never get tired
so we imagined that every healthcare
professional had this
agent like an assistant that had a
perfect memory that could help them in
any
important situation to make the best
decision possible
if the system is saving lives today it's
in part thanks to eu funding
the european parliament wants companies
like this to continue driving europe's
digital revolution
in order to nurture and grow similar
high-tech startups
meps are back in digital europe
[Music]
the 7.6 billion euro program will help
build europe's strategic digital
capacity
making these technologies available to
ordinary people and businesses
the program will invest in super
computing and developing artificial
intelligence
as well as ensuring that you use cyber
security and digital sovereignty
from health care transport and the
environment to better public
administration and vocational training
in new technologies
parliament wants digital europe to boost
the eu's competitivity
as well as help it reach climate
neutrality by twenty fifty